le corps de julie 15 ans a été retrouvé
tout près d'un cours d'eau tout comme
celui d'une autre victime cette fois ci
est une femme de 38 ans dans le corps
semble avoir été déposés dans un
périmètre voisin autant de coïncidences
troublantes qui s'ajoutait une troisième
affaire la mort de la petite jeanne
marie 11 ans dans la même région
dans les ardennes les pouilles qui ont
commencé ce matin au château de sceaux
tous ont permis de découvrir un premier
corps sur les indications du tueur en
série michel fourniret et de sa femme
une journée classée orange sur les
routes des départs en vacances plus
d'une centaine de kilomètres de bouchons
avec de forts ralentissements en
rhône-alpes sur la route du soleil le
départ du tour de france avec à liège le
prologue 188 coureurs ont pris le départ
l'américain lance armstrong est arrivé à
la deuxième place de ce contre l'amour
tourisme de rêve tourisme 5 étoiles une
industrie qui génère des milliards
d'euros et qui donne envie la grande
saison à cannes images paquet classe
voilà monsieur bonsoir commençons ce
journal par la sphère du tueur en série
michel fourniret dans les ardennes au
château de sceaux tout un premier corps
a été découvert depuis ce matin des
fouilles étaient entreprises avec la
coopération sur place de michel
fourniret de sa femme qui avait désigné
deux zones précises
après les aveux voici vraisemblablement
le temps d'épreuve amaury guibert david
fossard bien encadrés menotté michel
fourniret est face à son passé dans son
ancien domaine aujourd'hui un terrain de
fouilles macabre le château de soutou où
sont arrivés ce matin policiers et
magistrats belges et français dans ces
hectares de terrains des engins de
chantier sont à l'oeuvre
michel fourniret a avoué avoir enterrée
ici deux de ses victimes
toute la journée il a fait l'aller
retour entre les deux endroits qu'il a
indiqué aux enquêteurs sa femme monique
olivier lui succède à chaque fois pour
confronter les déclarations en fin
d'après midi les recherches donnent
leurs premiers résultats
dans le cas de des recherches que nous
faisons nous voulons retrouver un
premier corps ce qui donc accrédite pour
l'instant les déclarations que nous à pq
cherche on y est les indices que nous
avons recueillis naturellement il est
trop tôt pour dire davantage puisque
nous sommes en cours bien sûr
d'identification de ce premier corps
michel fourniret sa femme sont arrivés
tôt ce matin de belgique
un transfert sous haute sécurité avec
les policiers français l'un d'entre eux
changent les menottes de monique olivier
ici au centre de l'image derrière michel
fourniret les yeux bandés pour ne pas
qu'ils sachent que sa femme assiste aux
fouilles
selon ses aveux deux corps reposent
autour du château celui de jeanne marie
des rameaux au disparu en mars 89 à
charleville mézières et celui
d'elisabeth brichet disparu la même
année à namur deux victimes de
nationalité
d'où cette opération d'envergure qui
mobilise plus d'une centaine d'hommes il
on vous retrouve cette frontière directe
de donchery après la découverte d'un
premier corps on imagine que les fous
ils vont bien sûr se poursuivre demain
et on attend les premiers résultats de
l'identification
oui effectivement béatrice mais vous
savez dans ce type d'affaires dans ce
type d'enquêté souvent et bien la phase
d'identification des corps qui est la
plus longue et la plus difficile ne voue
pas oublier que michel fourniret et bien
enterré ses victimes il ya plus de 15
ans et donc la police judiciaire va
devoir travailler sur des prélèvement
infime
ils vont devoir effectuer des tests adn
et les résultats ne devraient pas être
connus avant plusieurs jours
même si les choses semblent évoluer
assez vite on m'a appris il ya quelques
minutes
et bien que l'on aurait peut-être
retrouvé le corps d'une deuxième victime
et quelques traces de vêtements qui
pourraient appartenir à la petite jade
marie la victime française quand on
recherche et bien le devrait se
poursuivre cette nuit jusqu'à la tombée
de la nuit justement michel fourniret
semble toujours aussi coopératif c'est
ce que nous ont dit ce que nous ont dit
les enquêteurs il semble calme il parle
avec sang froid et surtout il apporte
beaucoup de détails et de précision sur
les endroits où ils auraient enterré ces
corps et donc les recherches et bien
pourrait se terminer
mais ce soir merci et yan fang il n'y a
désormais plus aucun doute huit jours
après la disparition de julie son corps
a été retrouvé ce matin dans un cours
d'eau des traces de sang de
l'adolescente retrouvée dans la voiture
de pierre bodein avait amené à la mise
en examen et l'incarcération de celui
qui est surnommé pierrot le fou un homme
au lourd passé judiciaire libéré il ya
quelques mois et voilà que dans cette
même région le corps d'une adulte cette
fois ci une femme de 38 ans a été
découvert là aussi dans un cours d'eau
d'abord le point de l'enquète anouk
burel chili à dos derrière ces arbres la
police scientifique s'affairent c'est là
qu'on a retrouvé le corps de julie dans
un ruisseau à moitié dénudée en état de
décomposition selon les enquêteurs il
serait là et depuis plusieurs jours la
police scientifique a retrouvé ici des
éléments qui ne laisse pas de doute sur
l'identité du corps selon toute
vraisemblance il s'agit du corps de
julie des éléments qui me permettent de
le dire sont les effets vestimentaires
qui ont pu être trouvées sur les lieux
et dont elle était vécue notamment
d'amande son jogging t-shirt ses
chaussures sa casquette sa montre après
huit jours de recherches intenses c'est
le hasard qui a mené les gendarmes ici
entre les champs et les vignes endroit
discret loin des habitations dans les
gendarmes c'est un petit champ de vigne
ou un viticulteur vient soit rose et les
plans celui qui doit trouver opposé ce
matin pierre bodein reste le suspect
numéro un
on a retrouvé son adn sur le vélo de la
jeune fille et les traces de sang de
julie dans sa voiture il a toujours nié
les faits en ce qui concerne mon client
je me suis pas entretenu avec lui depuis
que j'ai l'information de la découverte
de ce corps
donc je ne sais pas si sa position va
changer ou s'il va rester dans sa
position dans la position de déni qui
l'a depuis depuis le début de cette
affaire
ce soir les enquêteurs emportent le
corps de julie l'autopsié permettra de
déterminer les circonstances exactes de
la mort de la jeune fille
force est de constater que les corps de
julie 14 ans de la petite jeanne marie
11 ans et d'edwige 38 ans a été
découverte dans un même secteur
à quelques kilomètres du village où
vivaient pierre bodein christelle
bertrand dans ces trois affaires
apparemment distinctes
il y à des coins si dense et bien
troublante
oui ce sont les enquêteurs eux-mêmes qui
qualifie ces coïncidences de troublantes
troublante d'abord effectivement du
point de vue de la géographie puisque
les trois corps ont été retrouvés dans
le même secteur tous distant à peu près
d'une quinzaine de kilomètres il se
trouve que au milieu de ce périmètre se
trouve l'endroit où vivait pierre bodein
des circonstances aussi troublante dans
le mode opératoire
je vous le rappelle julie a été retrouvé
dans un ruisseau à moitié dénudée et il
se trouve que les corps de jeanne marie
et d'edwige ont été retrouvés à peu près
dans des circonstances similaires trois
disparitions dans la même région en
l'espace de quinze jours on pourrait
facilement penser et les enquêteurs
aussi essaient de déterminer s'il
pourrait s'agir du même auteur alors
évidemment c'est le nom de pierre bodein
qui revient tout de suite dans les
esprits mais je vous rappelle que pierre
bodin est mis en examen pour l'instant
que dans une seule affaire celle de
l'enlèvement du dit et maintenant les
enquêteurs cherchent à savoir si celui
qu'on appelle pierrot le fou était dans
le secteur au moment de sa disparition
par pure coïncidence merci christelle
berthe rock de ces précisions et puis
j'ajoute que dans la sphère de la
disparition de jeunes marie ce 108
personnes qui sont maintenant mises en
examen deux jeunes femmes l'ont été
aujourd'hui pour non-assistance à
personnes en péril et non dénonciation
de crime ces deux personnes ne font en
fait partie du même environnement
familial que ces six autres mis en
examen et qu il ya dix jours jeanne
marie qui est par ailleurs aurait pu
subir des sévices sexuels et couettes
depuis jeudi pierre bodein
multirécidiviste a passé sa vie entre
l'hôpital psychiatrique et la prison sa
libération conditionnelle ne manque pas
de soulever de nombreuses questions
fallait-il le laisser sortir quelques
mois avant la fin de sa peine
un individu de ce genre doit-il être mis
sous une surveillance bien plus étroite
enfin que dit la loi française qui ne
cumulent pas les peines et autorise à
remettre dehors un homme potentiellement
dangereux
yasmina faveur depuis 1969 pierre bodein
a été condamné huit fois vol avec
violence hold up séquestration et viol
c'est le parcours de celui que l'on
surnomme pierrot le fou en 94
pierre bodein se retrouve à trois
reprises devant la cour d'assises trois
verdicts très lourd
19 15 et 30 ans de prison mais en france
ces peines ne peuvent pas se cumuler
le détenu aurait pu sortir de prison en
janvier 95
ils retrouvent la liberté 9 mois plus
tôt un principe très courant
conditionnelle il faut le savoir est
indispensable car s'il n'ya pas de
conditionnel on va pas réinsérer la
personne ont elle va sortir un jour donc
pour des personnes qui ont des profils
psychologiques psychiatriques qui sont
des récidives en faut absolument que
sous contrôle social soit sérieux mais
pierre bodein n'a pas été suivie
sérieusement une centaine de
strasbourgeois défiler vers le palais de
justice pour dire son indignation
je vous rappeler sans délinquance
sexuelle qui est reconnue par les
experts comme étant quelqu'un de très
dangereux les psychiatres continue de
croire dans les bienfaits de la
libération conditionnelle mais ils font
un constat amer la france est très en
retard
elle n'a pas les moyens de suivre les
détenus à la sortie l'oise 81,18
prévoyait à peu près 16 mille détenus et
10000 personnes suivies dehors et on n'a
jamais prévu les crédits et les moyens
pour suivre ses 10000 personnes dehors
combien de condamnés ont un profil
comparable à celui de pierre bodein
aujourd'hui une récidive suffit et toute
une politique pénale est remise en cause
après le verdict d'outreau qui a laissé
un sentiment de confusion et
d'incompréhension nos équipes sont
retournées la tour du renard là où se
sont déroulés les faits et sur place on
espère pouvoir tourner la page et
retrouver sa dignité aux médias guy m'a
vincent ferreira vincent kelner
la honte de ceux qui n'habitent pas le
quartier est presque aussi grande que
celle de ceux qui l'habitent pacifié %
valls se retrouve pas avec l' affaire
d'outreau la réputation de la tour du
renard s'est effondré pédophilie inceste
maltraitance les habitants du quartier
ont dû endosser les pires qualificatif
j'ose même pas deux ans que j'habite ici
quoi parce que c'est tout de suite
j'ose même produire le nom de la ville
parmi eux ont déjà vu d'en bas elle gît
sur le sens boulogne puis les gens ils
disent ouais mais voyez pas tu as à
outreau il y en a même qui m'appellent
monsieur pédophiles que j'arrive à n'en
plus cinquième étage de la tour des
maires lui là où les faits ont été
commis la justice est passée de quoi
normalement tourner la page mais la
sphère a retenti dans la france entière
et éclabousse encore l'ensemble des
habitants de la ville se sont sentis
salis comment fortement et injustement
sadi on les a considérés comme des
alcooliques les paresseux et méritait
pas ça vraiment une montée comme des
innocents condamnés à tort les habitants
doutent roux réclame aujourd'hui leur
réhabilitation
et puis dans les ardennes à l'instant le
procureur vient de confirmer la
découverte d'un deuxième corps au
château de soutou dans le sud du
finistère dans l'archipel des glénan le
corps d'un adolescent de 17 ans a été
retrouvé sans vie ce matin le jeune
homme était en stage de voile une
autopsie sera réalisée lundi l'hypothèse
de l'homicide n'est pas celle
privilégiée pour l'instant par les
gendarmes dans l'actualité de ce samedi
la première vague de départs sur les
routes des grandes vacances une journée
classée orange par bison futé comme il
fallait s'y attendre
les bouchons se sont multipliées les
heures passant avec des points noirs
notamment rhône alpes
didier guyot philippe évêques
un petit coucou les cheveux au vent sur
la route du soleil
et tant pis s'il faut ton dur et
bouchons et ralentissements autoroute
surchargé au tour de lyon ternay et
vienne et surtout entre valence et
orange jusqu'à 100 km de ralentissements
milieu de journée mais des
automobilistes reste souriant malgré la
circulation la fatigue on parle pour
après
décompressez sur place et c'est bien
trop de soleil et de devoirs ou trois
chemins non on suit
je suis contente de partir
c'est ça tranquillement de jeu manu
réponse en deux jours comme ça on est
bien à hélices de stressé fatigué
stressé c'est déjà les vacances le temps
et le temps s'écoule également
tranquillement sur les aires de repos
des lieux envahis par les vacanciers non
seulement on reprend des forces
mais on peut également goûté à des
activités sportives inconnue c'est pour
dissocier effectivement les parents les
enfants bas ça leur permet comme ça de
faire de l'initiation parce qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément ils connaissent pas
forcément l'activité fini
l'automobiliste pied au plancher qui
veut tout faire pour arriver rapidement
désormais la journée du départ et sa
cohorte de bouchons c'est partie
intégrante des vacances en débouchant
finalement c'est cet accessoire parce
qu'on sait qu'au bout il ya le soleil la
mer le sable et les doigts de pied en
éventail donc c'est plutôt sympa ce soir
pour beaucoup la voiture étant singaré
les vacances débutent vraiment partons
pour millau traditionnellement et les
bouchons font partie du paysage estival
ce devrait être le dernier était le
viaduc en construction sera achevée en
décembre prochain véronique goguen
frédéric bibal
la campagne de millau il ne la verront
plus au ralenti l'an prochain les
touristes ne devrait plus être coincé
comme ça dans les bouchons sont fait
maintenant presque une nappe 1
dans le bouchon pour accéder remis l'eau
l'année prochaine ils passeront 240
mètres au dessus du tarn le viaduc de
contournement de la ville sera achevé en
décembre pour les vacanciers qui sont
pressés d'aller au bord de la mer je
pense que oui ça fera une aubaine ce
viaduc est passée comme le viaduc les en
construction parfaite
il vient du c'est possible ou alors on
passera quand même par millau sachant
que viaduc est ouvert peut-être que les
gens parce qu'en plus ce pas réducteur
que les automobilistes passent dessus ou
à côté ce qui est sûr c'est que le
viaduc va continuer d'attirer des
touristes
seule la vraie frites du bord de route
s'inquiètent les commerces du
centre-ville le voit le viaduc comme un
produit d'appel
vraiment une perte de chiffre d'affaires
continuer après baignade nous avons
toutes les gorges du tarn nous avons pas
mal de pas mal de sites dans tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est naturel est relevé
depuis deux ans les touristes viennent
de plus en plus nombreux spécialement
pour voir le viaduc il on profite pour
visiter aussi millau une vraie pause
qu'il s'accorde rarement sur la route
des bouchons et pour ce premier week-end
de grands départs nous avons choisi de
faire la route d'accompagner tout au
long du chemin une famille qui préfèrent
conduire la nuit reportage françois
julien petit noir mat les barrois
00h30 la famille roberti roule depuis 4
direction l'italie comme beaucoup de
vacanciers ils ont choisi la fraîcheur
et la fluidité du trafic la nuit mais
surtout la tranquillité si les enfants
s'endorment sans cesse les occuper les
faire dessiner s'arrêter souvent et à jo
des envies de beebe finalement la nuit
bas ils nous embêtent moindre on n'est
plus qu'à une heure du matin la pause
café et pari réussi pour les parents
silence radio à l'arrière à cette
heure-là sur les aires d'autoroutes les
voitures servent d'autels de fortune les
voyageurs nocturne ne sont plus que des
ombres
seuls les thermos de café sortent des
coffres c'est le carburant du conducteur
nous empêcher de dormir
fait du bien vous avez tendance à
somnoler à pignan j'arrête avant en la
fatigue dans la savane tellement on
écoutait m'enthousiasme de partout en
vacances la fatigue effectivement
beaucoup ne la sentent pas et ne
s'arrête pas c'est le fléau des
conducteurs 500 morts par an la nuit
entre minuit et 6 heures du matin le
risque d'avoir un accident est deux fois
plus élevé qu'en journée avec cet
accident si des accidents dus aussi au
comportement de certains conducteurs
les gens ont tendance à rouler plus vite
de nuit du fait de la fluidité des
circulations la famille roberti devrait
poser ses valises ce soir a brandi dans
le sud de l'italie après 30 heures de
route en face ce tragique accident sur
la bande d'arrêt d'urgence de
l'autoroute a36 un gendarme a été fauché
par une voiture il est mort peu de temps
après les trois occupants de la voiture
sont grièvement blessés la voiture c'est
en fait déporter vers la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence en raison d'une crevaison
c'est hier que les candidats au bac
qu'ont découvert s'il était admis ou
s'il devrait recommencer immédiatement
révisé pour être fin prêt lundi les
oraux de rattrapage se dérouleront toute
la semaine prochaine et d'une gène mann
c'était hier déception sabrina apprend
qu'elle doit passer l'orage comme des
milliers d'autres élèves ce premier
week-end de vacances se transforme en
course contre la montre plus que trois
jours pour réviser
elle a 54 points à rattraper un sur 20
en maths
elle a fait appel à une copine pour
surmonter l'énorme blocage qu'elle a
dans cette matière j'ai pas confiance en
mon mac ont à faire bouger pas confiance
en moi devons que je panique je mets
trois minutes avant de chercher une
réponse quelques bêtes devant moi pour
ces professeurs ce week-end aussi sera
un week-end de travail
objectif aider gratuitement leurs élèves
leur redonner confiance avec quelques
construit par exemple que faire des
vingt minutes qui précèdent l'oral
ça va très vite c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas rédiger un brouillon de manière trop
détaillé d'accord donc tu va proposer la
meilleure solution préconisée par les
professeurs faire un plan de travail
le sujet c'est une question relativement
courte relativement fermé qui appelle
des connaissances très précise très
rigoureuse s'ils les ont et s'il arrive
à les organiser de manière cohérente
il n'y a pas de raison pour qu'il n'ait
pas de très bonnes notes pour ces
enseignants il s'agit de rassurer certes
mais sans perdre de vue l'essentiel
rattraper un élève s'est essayé de
sortir de cet élève tout ce qu'il a pu
retenir de l'année
il suffit parfois d'un tout petit déclic
voilà tu as compris tu vois tu vois des
gens en deux secondes je te jeter les
comprendre tu vois tu peux qu à fait
capable d'y arriver
petit hic avec le rassemblement des élus
socialistes à la mutualité à paris
plusieurs centaines d'entre eux portant
leur écharpe se sont retrouvés pour
préparer l'alternance affirme françois
hollande qui comptait tirer parti dès
maintenant de la victoire du ps aux
dernières élections
mais il y avait quelques grands absents
véronique saint-olivier rancoeur
certains
lavrov
françois hollande ne s'attache pas aux
détails l'important aujourd'hui pour les
socialistes c'est de s'afficher ensemble
et de sourire l'objectif est à l'avenir
après la victoire des régionales et des
européennes près de 600 élus socialistes
se sont donc retrouvés ce matin la
mutualité à paris
laurent fabius en grand organisateur
mène l'attaqué contre le gouvernement
ils se défaussent sur leurs
prédécesseurs ils se défaussent sur
leurs successeurs il se défausse sur les
salariés
il se défausse sur les collectivités et
cette défausse nous ne l'acceptons pas
mais julien dray c'est que cela se passe
aussi en coulisses il ya d'abord
françois hollande le secrétaire général
du parti qui médiatise le message et
enfonce le clou face à une droite qui à
la fois veut passer en force qui
n'écoutent rien du message des français
du printemps électoral et qui se dispute
en son sommet comme par une espèce de
surenchère au plus libéral et bien nous
devons la gauche être utile aux français
et puis il ya les grandes manoeuvres
engagées pour les présidentielles de
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un affichage de
votre part derrière le drapeau fabius
mois hier j'ai signé avec oscar
lorsqu'il essaye d'être discret on
essaye de dire finalement vous savez ce
type n'a rien à dire donc c'est pas la
peine de s'intéresser à lui
lorsqu'il parle dans le cadre des
responsabilités qui laissant les iem en
dieu ou la la quelles sont ses
arrière-pensées éviter que les rivalités
de personnes ne masquent le projet
d'alternance
à gauche on sait que la confiance des
français en dépend et qu'elle est
fragile
et puis ce sondage qui devrait
intéresser et l'ump et nicolas sarkozy
en particulier en question le cumul ou
non d'un ministère et de la présidence
de l'ump pour jacques chirac on ne peut
pas exercer de fonction qu'en pense donc
les français 62% sont d'accord avec le
président de la république 36%
n'approuve pas ce principe et puis
concernant nicolas sarkozy 49% préfère
qu'il reste ministre 23% qu'il soit élu
à l'automne prenant ainsi la succession
d'alain juppé
partout pour l'indonésie et plus
précisément pour bali où un français
depuis quatre ans a été condamné à vie
michaël blanc n'a jamais cessé de clamer
son innocence et de dire que les kilos
de haschich qu'ils transportaient dans
des bouteilles de plongée avait été
placé là son insu les élections
présidentielles qui ont lieu lundi
prochain sont un fragile espoir de
changement
pour michaël blanc et pour sa mère
hélène qui vivent désormais là bas pour
être prêt de son fils reportage
les proches aussi un chaume
chaque matin hélène prend la route de la
prison de kerobokan pour rendre visite à
son fils michael avec cette fois
l'espoir d'une libération possible à la
faveur des changements politiques
depuis quelques temps il ya un
changement une volonté de changement en
indonésie et
ça c'est n'importe quoi sans différence
c'est la présence d'hélène à bali qui
aident michael à tenir le coup depuis
quatre ans et demi il est détenu ici
avec 600 autres prisonniers trafic en
chef de bande
mais aussi deux des terroristes accusés
d'avoir organisé l'attentât de bali à
l'abri du regard de ses gardiens nous
avons pu filmer la rencontre des laines
et de michael et la porte à manger
chaque jour car la nourriture de la
prison passe mal et mickaël va mieux
même s'il fume toujours deux à trois
paquets de cigarettes par jour
ces conditions de vie se sont améliorées
alors
michaël blanc et sa mère s'accroche
d'aujourd'hui à l'espoir d'un accord de
transfert qui lui permettrait de purger
sa peine en france
avec bien sûr la possibilité d'un
allègement pour cette peine de prison à
vie et il va beaucoup mieux qu'à une
certaine époque donc je pense ça tient
aussi à son moral se sentir plus
soutenue par l'extérieur
avant il ya des commandes donc c'était
une toute petite force et puis petit à
petit en son temps qui est beaucoup plus
de gens qui s'intéressent à son cas et
qui se motive donc ça ça le sale
fortifie hélène ne quitte jamais ben ali
plus de quelques jours pour renouveler
son visa
c'est peut-être sa persévérance qui
aidera michael à sortir de sa prison à
l'autre bout du monde une image plutôt
insolite celle de colin powell le
secrétaire d'état américain habillé
comme l'as des village people chanter et
danse sur scène en trouver de la
délégation américaine une prestation
pour la conférence annuelle
l'association des nations de l'asie du
sud est la tradition veut que les
participants l'église et il ya quelques
années
madeleine albright était apparu en et
victor pellerin l'actualité sportive
particulièrement riche avec d'abord le
tour de france le prologue a eu lieu cet
après midi à l'aise sous un ciel de
grisaille lance armstrong termine second
à moins de deux secondes du vainqueur un
suisse natale de reims à 6,22 bas
reviennent cancellara n'en croit pas ses
yeux
il vient de réussir la plus belle
performance de sa carrière
aujourd'hui à liège le suisse a battu
tout le monde même les amstrong toujours
très bien accompagné le quintuple
vainqueur du tour s'en va sans demander
son reste sans doute un peu vexé sans
doute un peu déçu d'avoir été dominé par
ce jeune coureur longiligne cet après
midi cancellara a pris tous les risques
pour parcourir les 6 km sont du parcours
à la vitesse moyenne de 53 km heure 500
c'est un grand bonheur pour moi que
cette victoire que ce maillot ça me
laisse sans voix
si armstrong n'a pas gagné il a tout de
même fait taire ceux qui doutaient de sa
condition physique
deuxième à deux petites secondes
l'américain devance jan ullrich fonds
grand rival de près de 15 secondes
presque un détail sur l'ensemble du tour
mais l'ascendant psychologique est pris
christophe moreau lui n'a pas perdu son
temps il se classe 8e à 12 secondes du
vainqueur
à 33 ans le français est à l'heure au
rendez vous du tour quant à fabian
cancellara
perché sur son podium il a déjà la tête
dans les étoiles à 23 ans c'est son
premier maillot jaune peut être pas le
dernier
plus de 200 contrôles antidopage sont
prévues pendant ce tour de france qui
s'achèvera le 25 juillet prochain
un dispositif qui devrait permettre de
lever toute suspicion a l'envoyant dans
quelle ambiance se déroule ce premier
tour de chauffe
julien bobot l'art ancien 210 personnes
dans les rues de liège de mémoire de
wallons armand le tour de france n'avait
attiré autant de spectateurs c'est pas
si souvent que la grande boucle passe
par ici alors forcément pour beaucoup
pas question de rater l'événement
il ya quelque temps on pensait pas les
voir ici à liège et puis depuis deux ans
nos deux ans n'a été choisi et à partir
de là on joue ici on attendait on a
parlé et soit là aujourd'hui c'est
splendide 6 km de parcours le long de la
meuse pas toujours facile de trouver une
place devant l'affluence il faut ruser
être au ras du sol au prendre un peu de
hauteur c'est selon pour ces étudiants
c'est plutôt confort 5 étoiles leur
appartement donne cela ni d'arrivée
problème nous ne pouvons pas accueillir
tous leurs amis il a donc fallu
effectuer une sélection on va avoir de
problèmes avec nos amis afin qu pour
internet
donc on a pris les 25 premiers voilà
donc de répondre à une certaine heure un
certain jo et les 25 premiers ont été
pris voir passer le tour de france ce
n'est pas qu'ils affaire de spécialistes
c'est allons par exemple prend tous les
courants en photo et peu importe leur
performance j'habite à 160 km en
allemagne
et moi j'adore voir tous ces garçons
avec leurs muscles et leur vélocité
la fête aura duré la majeure partie de
la journée après plusieurs heures de
boue certains n'ont plus le courage de
voir passer les derniers et pourtant il
ne faut pas hésiter à se reposer car
demain la première étape par de liège du
tennis à wimbledon avec qu'est la finale
dames c'est la russe maria sharapova qui
a terrassé la favorite serena williams
numéro un mondiale
la tenante du titre depuis deux ans
s'est inclinée 6 1 6 4 la jeune russe
à tout juste 17 ans gillain benedetto
elle est belle elle est russe et à 17
ans tout juste elle vient de s'offrir
son premier tournoi du grand chelem à
wimbledon en finale cet après midi maria
sharapova a créé la sensation en
balayant serena williams double tenante
du titre la musculeuse américaine a été
battu à son propre jeu en puissance du
fond du court
maria sharapova physique de mannequin et
visage d'ange mais compétitrices au
moral d'acier
score final 6 1 6 4 en un peu plus d'une
heure seulement après le succès de
myskina à roland-garros les russes
poursuivent leur razzia sur le circuit
féminin
sharapova a du talent et une plastique
qui rappelle sa compatriote kournikova
à une différence près la jolie maria
elles gagnent l'euro 2004 avec deux
mâles la finale le portugal affronte la
grèce une affiche inédite et deux
sélectionneurs étrangers devenus et des
idoles dans leur pays d'adoption manuel
tisser nadine picard dans le sillage de
ses joueurs un pays tout entier s'envole
vers les sommets
des milliers de portugais en moto ou en
bateaux ont accompagné la sélection
mercredi dernier en demi finale ils ont
répondu à l'appel d'un homme devenu en
quelques semaines un héros national
luiz felipe scolari exhorte tout un
peuple à se lever derrière son équipe
il est brésilien champion du monde mais
parle comme un enfant de la nation
et aussi grâce à cet élan populaire
je sens qu'on a réussi à faire avancer
notre patriotisme et notre amour du
portugal à mort dans les rues de
lisbonne fleurissent des affiches à la
gloire de scolari car il gouverne les
stars d'une poigne de fer avec un sens
tactique qui a fait merveille dans la
compétition presque tous ces choix ont
été couronnés de succès alors l'histoire
d'amour va se poursuivre jusqu'en 2006
avec le président de la fédération nous
avons consenti au mariage avec de bons
sentiments
l'alliance est là nous sommes mariés
pour deux ans de plus athènes aussi à
son idole étrangère responsable du seul
accroc dans le parcours de scolari à
l'euro otto rehhagel le sélectionneur de
la grèce est rarement un joyeux lurons
mais l'allemand a remis de l'ordre dans
ses cheveux et dans la sélection rigueur
et engagement physique
c'est la recette du roi auto avec ses
ingrédients
les grecs ont déjà battu le portugal
sorti la france et la république tchèque
deux des favoris du tournoi l'allemand
démonstratif et le flegmatique brésilien
deux écoles s'affrontent demain en
finale
trois semaines après le match
d'ouverture grecs et portugais se
retrouvent
l'heure de la revanche ou d'une nouvelle
surprise premier grand festival de l'été
les eurockéennes de belfort en attend
90000 spectateurs en trois jours
arrivent et les médias ludovic tourte
premier week-end de juillet premiers
grands départs en vacances et bien sûr
premiers bouchons
trente mille personnes bloqués au péage
des européennes la fête va durer pendant
trois jours la guitare dans tous ses
états ils sont venus pour ça
soit quatre ans
souvent
dans un festival il y à des découvertes
franz ferdinand iv écossais dans le vent
de grands noms que le public aime et
puis du moins classique l'orchestré à
cordes de l'école nationale de musique
de belfort
du classique à jouer en de rock de
jeunes musiciens invités à accompagner
sur scène la chanteuse anne pierné
qui est là pour faire le pen ayant des
morceaux
point d'orgue de la première soirée
placebo au micro brian molko
bah
et puis à 3 heures du matin quand la
fatigue augmente que la température
baisse s'offrir un dernier plaisir avant
de rentrer sous la tente un concert
gratuit de 10 minutes très privé pas
plus de trois spectateurs face préfet à
mes chansons sont des chansons que d'eau
calme et intime donc je vais chercher un
lieu calme et intime un taxi pour salles
de concert 3 aux eurockéennes
certains chanteurs la nuit rsa de
prendre c'est
la mode masculine pourrait faire des
ravages l'époque et aux hommes et les
grands stylistes redoublent
d'imagination pour s'engouffrer dans ce
nouveau marché
sur le podium les connexions de galliano
et de jean paul gaultier d'abord du
spectacle estelle cola et sylvain
gauthier pour parler mode nous sommes
désormais paris cet hiver
fini le temps des costumes croisés sur
les podiums
le marché du masculin étant un défilé
c'est avant tout pour marquer les
esprits et la provocation ça c'est
vendre alors rien de très surprenant
dans la mise en scène d'un mariage
homosexuel chez jean paul gaultier à qui
l'on doit les plus folles soda ce un
moyen comme un autre de servir la marque
tout entière la fonction d'un défilé
c'est plutôt une fonction événementiel
le défilé doit créer l'événement et est
au service d'une marque
d'ailleurs c'est lui qui a presque tout
inventé copié depuis ses oeufs dans
cette école on applique désormais les
mêmes stratégies marketing pour l'homme
que celles qui ont fait de l'or pour la
femme la déplie comme ça sent encore
plus fort que des pages de publicité des
magazines au niveau marketing face vous
et loire et télévision du coup
nortene magazine ça va vous interloqué
ça les regarde et vous allez vous en
souvenir
voilà je pense que ça vous frappe
marketing communication image tout cela
semble parfaitement maîtrisé d'ailleurs
lieu ce soir
galliano a littéralement envoûté la
salle avec un show un show parfaitement
huilée
oui je pense que le nom ils sont prêts
pour ça
je suis sûr je vois le reste du crédit
le magasin ouais c'est bien très bien
même très très très très très envie à
plein de gens et l'homme il est
difficile à réveiller
voilà je pense que oui pourtant même les
mentalités évoluent reste aujourd'hui à
faire de l'argent dans un secteur en
pleine évolution certes mais encore un
peu timide
venons en ce début des vacances au
tourisme qui fait rêver le tourisme de
luxe est une industrie qui génère des
milliards d'euros du tourisme 5 étoiles
à cannes jean jacques dufour jean moulin
si j'étais riche pour attraper les gros
poissons la clientèle du tourisme de
luxe elle qui dépensent des milliers
d'euros pour faire des ronds dans l'ô
canada s'ils viennent occuper
je dirais même qu'elle est pour les
appétits cannes c'est mieux que la
riviera italienne
c'est mieux que la riviera espagnol et
c'est pas trop cher si vous voulez payer
moins il avait calé dans une tente
c'est touristes qui préfèrent les palha
son camping ne représente que 3% des 700
millions de voyageurs internationaux
c'est peu mais leur pouvoir d'achat est
énorme d'ailleurs et toujours à propos
d'argent
il paraît que le nombre de milliardaires
a augmenté effectivement il ya de plus
en plus de riches la statistique récente
prouve qu'il y à 11% de milliardaires en
plus en 2003 par rapport à 2002 c'est
très encourageant pour tous les métiers
du luxe et ça nous promet de très belles
années très encourageant surtout quand
on sait combien ce genre de vacancier
peut dépenser par jour
il tourne autour de 12 mille euros par
jour 12000 euros par jour oui parce que
des vacancières suivre ça fait des
vacances de qualité
après les émirs les nouveaux riches
russes la croisette attend maintenant
l'arrivée des chinois et des indiens
enfin disons plutôt des chinois et des
indiens qui ont réussi dans les affaires
ce titre on a investi 1 5 million
d'euros sur la plage sur laquelle nous
sommes en ce moment et dans le hall et
la construction de nouvelles suites au
martinez plus de 12 millions d'euros ces
trois dernières années
comme vous le savez on n'attrape pas les
mouches avec du vinaigre avec du
vinaigre peut-être pas mais avec des
langoustines au caviar il paraît que
c'est du billard
abbas est évident c'est évident aux
mains au mas je pense la meilleure
cuisine du monde on ne la laverai cuivre
et cuisent de région qu'aucun autre pays
non à travers le monde
donc c'est notre grande richesse
culturelle c'est évident c'est quoi pour
vous le luxe c'est une définition
le luxe c'est un très beau décor c'est
surtout le service saas est un des
choses les plus importantes on peut les
chouchouter le tourisme de luxe est une
grosse affaire 150 milliards de dollars
de recettes annuelles c'est un beau
gâteau un gâteau que les professionnels
du secteur se dispute avec âpreté né
dans une compétition féroce civile et
mondialement c'est pas une compétition
simple puisque tout est des villes qui
veulent attirer justement les pros
poisson en elle même aussi essaie de
faire des événements essaye d'attirer
les gens c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile et surtout rien n'est définitif
ce que je veux dire
et oui là comme ailleurs le vent peut
tourner si j'étais riche des lieux de
l'aude
non
avant de refermer ce journal le revenant
aux premiers titres de l'actualité dans
l' affaire fourniret
les corps retrouvés au château de sceaux
tous sont bien ceux de la belge
elisabeth brichet et de la française
jeanne marie des marots c'est ce
qu'indiquent les produits l'épreuve
procureur informations qui nous parvient
instant ainsi se termine cette édition
jean macé notre attention tout de suite
la météo patrice drevet 20h55 que fort
boyard présenté par olivier minne mais
sarah lelouch serrures 45 le dernier
journal jean claude renoult quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 13h excellente en soit
récompensé